Do you know, Dr. Jack Cruz?
And if so, I would love your thoughts on his teaching
about the son and mitochondria.
I don't know.
I do know of him.
And somebody asked a question about him.
I think last summer, they were,
and I looked up more things on him.
I've never interviewed him on my podcast.
I don't believe, but I don't know
what he teaches about the son and mitochondria.
I do know that there was some information going around
again, this is really so careful.
There's so much not corrected information
going around social media.
There's one guy who is a carpenter in my house.
He's become a real good friend of mine.
He's built some bars for me and stuff.
He said, oh, you should never wear sunglasses
because you need the sun to hit your eyes.
And that's blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And it's like, you know, he doesn't listen
if I try to tell him anything.
I just nodded and said, thank you.
But that is so not true.
You realize stimulation on your eyes with the sun.
Is that bad for you?
No, it's not bad for you.
But it does stimulate your sympathetic sense.
That's the whole purpose of it.
It's to stimulate your sympathetic sense.
Do I need more sympathetic stimulation?
I don't know about you, but I need more
parasympathetic stimulation.
Talk about it balance.
I am way overly sympathetic stimulator, okay?
You know, I deal with it.
I stress it my life.
I don't need the sunlight, you know,
saying somebody that, you know,
doesn't know what they're talking about with the nervous system
that everybody should not wear sunglasses.
If you are overly sympathetic dominant,
you should be wearing sunglasses
because that will block out some of the light
and calm down your sympathetic.
So just this information like that,
it's just damaging to people.
So and it just seems like so many people
say these things that are kind of outlandish
so that they can get more likes and more followers
and that bothers me.